hi there I'm back I didn't give up I
never give up surely any of you who have
been watching my videos know that I'm
passionate I love learning languages I'm
for sure not going to give up Korean is
difficult but I definitely feel that
I've made so much progress and and the
progress is often hard to notice but
when we casually there's there's a this
accumulation of improvement that is
suddenly noticeable today I had a
conversation with a Korean tutor a link
who lives in Paris we spoke in Korean I
did the best I have ever done in terms
of speaking somewhat more smoothly
understanding what she was saying
although I Cajun I had to ask what what
she was saying and so he spoke in Korean
for half an hour
then we spoke a little bit in English
and then we spoke in French now people
wonder why learn languages this tutor
her English was very good but with a
noticeable Korean accent what I thought
was a Korean accent then we spoke in
French
her French was flawless impeccable I
thought I was speaking to a French
person and she has been studying in
France for four years all her friends
are French she's in the you know luxury
goods business or she's studying to get
into the luxury goods business I'm sure
that's an interesting business and one
that you know Paris obviously is is the
place to go and do those studies but
here's a person who is extremely fluent
first of all in our native language of
course and in English excellent English
and her French is just to blow you away
earlier today I spoke to Sergey who
lives in in Belarus who is my Russian
tutor we spoke for half an hour he had
just come back from Italy he's been
studying Italian at link I haven't
spoken to him in Italian but I I know he
was looking for some content and
recommended to him Alioto della Sera
that I do it which he thanked me for so
he's much
be pretty good in Italian I know his
English is very good I didn't check up
to see how what other language is he
studying at Linc that's why we study
languages that's why we don't give up
here is Sergey who goes to visit Italy
and communicate with people in Italian
here's my Korean tutor and she lives in
Paris and she's just fluent in French in
English as well as Korean that's what
it's all about um but I felt good today
I did some more listening to Kim jung-ho
I was in the office this morning I went
to the golf course this afternoon the
weather is getting better and tomorrow
it's supposed to rain in the next few
days so I figured I'd go there and and
work a bit on my golf game
of course I listened to Kim Yeon ha
going there and coming back got home
again went on my stepper and read and
listened on my iPad here I can read
through it and listen at the same time
and I pick up a little bit more but
there are a lot of blue unknown words
there so now I've got to sit down and go
through the blue unknown words if those
of you who are familiar with link
convert them into yellow links and then
once again listen to it and all of that
is fun it's an interesting the content
is enter I'm as happy like that
yesterday surely people would recognize
that it's out of character so never give
up you often don't notice that you're
making improvements and there are as I
mentioned before these Eureka moments
that make it all worthwhile
and ultimately when you become fluent
enough to do what Sergey is doing and
what I think was Clarissa with your name
in Paris and but I and so many others do
then it all becomes worthwhile so stay
the course and the next video that I do
will be on politics because actually I
like talking about politics
I like being interested in Canadian
politics international politics
I think citizens should be aware of and
inform themselves about events that are
taking place I want to talk a bit about
what I have sort of gained from
listening to various discussions mostly
in Russia including the very interesting
discussion with this dobkin who was the
candidate representing the party of
regions in Ukraine there for part of
Yanukovych is party pro-russian and
stuff like
I'm going to talk a little bit about my
impressions those of you who don't like
to hear political discussions please
avoid the next